all right we'll start with this from the
uh from the AP it says the Vatican has
defrocked an anti-abortion U.S priest
Frank Pavone for what it said were
Blasphemous Communications on social
media as well as persistent Disobedience
of his Bishop who repeatedly told him to
stop his partisan activism for Donald
Trump a letter to U.S Bishops of the
Vatican ambassador to the U.S uh
Archbishop Christopher Pierre obtained
Sunday so the decision against Pavone
who heads the anti-abortion group
priests for life has been taken had been
taken November 9th and that there was no
chance for an appeal
the phone has been in conflict with the
bishop of uh Amarillo Texas for over a
decade over his pro-life and partisan
political activities that came to a head
in 2016 when he put an aborted fetus on
an altar and posted a video of it on two
social media sites the video was
accompanied by a post saying that
Hillary Clinton the Democrat platform
would allow abortion to continue and
that Trump and the Republican platform
wanted to protect unborn children
um now
so they they defrock the priests what
they call Laya sizing the priest and uh
turning him into
kicking him out of the priesthood this
kind of thing does not happen I can tell
you if you're not Catholic this sort of
thing does not happen very often this is
a rare step
and in this case it's a rare step being
taken against one of the most prominent
pro-life
activists in the priesthood
not one of the most he's the most
prominent
pro-life priest in the country
and they kicked him out of the
priesthood
now
first of all uh
to the extent that this stems from the
video which this was back six years ago
with a video where he had the aborted
baby on the altar
from what I understand first of all
obviously the baby was given a proper
burial and it also was not a consecrated
altar from what I understand
which which which is an important detail
um this was an intentionally shocking
Act
meant to show the brutality and horror
of abortion now people find this sort of
thing unsettling of course they do they
should I do
but when you're fighting when you're
fighting an historic genocidal horror
the sort of thing that most people in
society prefer to turn away from
then you need to shock them awake
sometime you have to force them to
confront it visually
um and you know there's always this
debate the pro-life communities like to
what extent do we show the victim images
to what extent do we put that front and
center
and there could be a conversation about
the right context for that but what is
absolutely certain
is that you cannot allow the victims to
be entirely erased
what it looks like that this needs to be
seen the visuals need to be seen
and you take any other example in
history of people fighting against a a
genocidal horror
images were always crucially important
because you can describe it all you want
people need to see what it looks like
and also keep in mind these children are
usually dismembered and thrown out
literally as trash into a medical waste
dumpster
um that's usually what happens so father
Pavone rescued this child from that fate
it's very difficult to claim that he
what he did was somehow more
disrespecting to the victim than the
faith of that child's body would have
otherwise suffered which again would be
to be thrown out as trash
the point here is the opposite is to
show the victim's Humanity
and besides all that how is this
blasphemous
you know we could have an argument you
could say that it's inappropriate it's
shocking there's all kinds of
descriptions that you could that you
could uh come up with and we could argue
about whether they apply but Blasphemous
what's Blasphemous about that
and however you feel about that
um however you feel about it
the fact is that
if anything his sin here is being too
zealous too militant in the fight for
The Unborn something that I don't really
think is possible to be honest with you
the idea that he would be defrocked for
this kicked out of the priesthood is
just its grotesque especially
considering all of the priests who are
not kicked out
as I said this is a very
uncommon
uh measure that is taken it does not
happen often
I think maybe there was a time when it
was more common but these days things
like defrocking priests withholding
communion
excommunicating people
um these sorts of of kind of ultimate
punishments and measures are really
uncommon these days
and yet there are if you're going to
start doing that sort of thing
there are all there's there's a whole
line of people that should be far in
front of of Someone Like Father Frank
Pavone
James Martin
is maybe a name you've heard he's a
Jesuit heretic but I repeat myself
openly defies the church's teachings on
a number of central moral issues
especially sexuality
he he's a he's a gay pride flag waving
blasphemy blasphemer touting acceptance
of sexual sin promoting gay marriage and
all the rest of it
openly defying the church's moral
Authority moral teachings in fact he has
also stated explicitly that the Bible is
incorrect in its moral judgments on
homosexuality he acknowledges that those
judgments are in there but says that
it's incorrect
now he tweeted this a couple years ago
apparently quoting someone else but
clearly in in agreement he was quoting
him he said interesting where the Bible
mentions same-sex sexual behavior at all
it clearly condemns it I freely grant
that the issue is precisely whether the
biblical judgment is correct
the Bible sanctions slavery as well and
nowhere attacked it as unjust
oh nothing you know no big deal here
just a priest one of the most prominent
ones in the country saying that the the
moral teachings in the Bible are are not
correct
which of course raises all kinds of
questions that if it's not correct about
this then what else is it incorrect
about
is there any reason to think it's
correct about anything else
you have just
um totally undermined the moral
Authority
of the Bible
and as a priest you have undermined the
moral authority of the church that's
what that's what James Martin is doing
is he getting defrocked is he getting
laya-sized not anywhere close
instead priests like him are taken and
given positions of prominence you know
they're welcomed into the Vatican
they're put in positions of power
by this Pope Pope Francis who is an
absolute disgrace
he is a disgrace and a disaster
we'll leave it there for today uh moving
over to the members block hope to see
you there if not talk to you tomorrow
Godspeed
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]